[Applause]
and chris paul with his first finals
game
one he will not soon forget he's with
malika chris
after that first quarter you went
nuclear offensively
what sweat what lift for you
cage in the game i saw the shots they
were giving me and i was just missing
them
so i just kept trying to be aggressive
my guys got going and
campaigning and all the coaches been
talking about us playing with pace
i'm the old head that like to slow it
down sometimes but uh in this series we
got to play with pace
deandre and devin booker have both
talked about how much you mean to them
but watching them the connection you
guys had on the court today what did
that mean to you
it's trust this trust we've been
building all season now for these
moments
but we're gonna keep playing it's just
one game gotta stay locked in
before this game your coach monty
williams said that earlier today when he
was trying to go through the scheme
he was told enough coach enough talking
we just want to play
and now we see you waving at your family
what did it mean to you to
finally play in a fight even in my
family my homies
are here my dog came to support
our team said in the shoot around
sometimes less is more
you know you know there's a lot of
energy going into this game
we got one got to get another one and we
saw you getting your hand wrapped up
everything good you feeling good for
game two already i don't know what
you're talking about
there you go thanks so much chris i
appreciate you
mike back to you